I'm getting emotional thinking about
it's like I was hating on myself so much
at that time subject' her - catchy pop
music this tell me about playing at
general mayhem what's your favorite
thing about playing her she's so cool
it's been it's been very very satisfying
you know because I think a lot of
animated movies in the past have sort of
relied on these kind of archaic tropes
about what the female characters and
those movies can be and who they are
like a movie kind of sort of usurped
that idea from the beginning with the
first film and this film is really a
continuation of exploring the different
kinds of heroes and villains that you
can have in a movie and this one is
really something I've never seen before
so it's really thrilled to do the voice
for it how did you do the voice for her
because it was like I felt like it was
you know kind of modulate it was me yeah
there we go there is a tiny bit of
modulation on it just to make it sound
like I'm inside a helmet but I did look
sure going back in time the first movie
you did little indie called a short-term
12 how cool is it that you and brie
Larson are both in space wandering home
as being awesome female warriors it's
amazing I mean I'm so happy for everyone
that worked on that film that was a
really special experience Justin kind of
put together this incredible cast and I
felt so lucky to be there and watching
breath' career take off watching
Romney's career take off watching
keith's career take off like it's been
incredible like all of them are just
doing such incredible amazing
wonderful work in this world I'm like
I'm so happy to have had that experience
with them I got to talk about your high
school throwback photo amazing how old
were you in the photo I was 18 that was
my senior photo I begged my parent cuz
everyone in my high school like got
these like fancy senior photos and I
thank my mom and dad to get me them and
my mom was like alright if you really
want them we'll save up and got them for
you and I remember like choosing my ID
met that man earrings on I just got my
fresh haircut from Supercuts like yeah I
was really living my best life in that
photo that's the thing back then
everybody got glamour shot stuff and
your friends won't get them and you be
like now I want them I want one and you
know like really looking at that photo
I'm like Stephanie you were so in your
head about like how you didn't live up
like you weren't thin enough you weren't
pretty enough your skin wasn't clear
enough you you know XY and Z like I was
I'm getting emotional thinking about
it's like I was hating on myself so much
at that time and I think a lot of
teenagers are in that position and now I
look at that photo I'm like look at look
at how beautiful you are like you were
you just find you were doing your best
you know and like it makes me really
proud to like think about how far I've
come from like being in that place of
like really doubting myself and now I'm
like you're doing great girl yeah
[Music]
[Applause]